hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
strategies to achieve robustness in
clinical proteomics research
presented by dr michelle hill i am
christy joel of labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by agilent for more
information on our sponsor
click on the sponsor logo on the left
side of your screen or visit
agilent.com now let's get started i
would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's
live event if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen i
would now like to introduce today's
presenter
dr michelle hill associate professor
qimr burkhofer medical research
institute
brisbane australia for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr hill you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much christy and thanks
everyone for joining me today
i like to share my experiences on the
strategies
to achieve robustness in clinical
proteomics research
so firstly before we dig into
the details let's just have a brief
consideration on
why we want to do clinical proteomics
research
so we all know that genes makes proteins
and there are many different techniques
now that
enable us to measure the genome in the
transcriptome and they are well used
so is there really a need to
directly measure proteins well actually
yes
so proteins are the direct disease
targets for diagnostic tests
as well as for therapies and there are
many
tests now that actually use proteins so
between the gene level and the protein
level there are many different
steps and there are many studies now
that report they don't directly
translate
so indeed there is a real need to
directly study proteins
and furthermore there are many
modifications that occur at the protein
level
that cannot be predicted from the genome
or transcriptome
so there is an actual need and let me
share
an actual example with you so it's a bit
more
clear so the example i wanted to use
is the use of her2 inhibiting drugs in
her two positive
or her two amplified cancers now there
are many different tests that one can
use
to measure the amplification of her2
so for example you can use in situ
hybridization to detect the gene
amplification
and as shown on the side here there's a
method and it detects
this amplification in the nucleus
on the other hand you can also use
immunohistochemistry
to detect the protein and because it's a
receptor
it's on the cell surface and now
sometimes it will be
it's important to detect the actual
protein that's on the cell surface
because in certain cases the protein may
not actually make it to the cell surface
it may be mislocalized
inside the cell in which case the her2
targeted
drugs will not really work because the
target are not on the cell surface
and a third method to detect her2
amplification
is actually a completely proteomic
method
because her2 is can be shared into the
serum
and that's a quick a minimally invasive
way
to detect excess or amplified her2
by measuring the protein in the serum
and so this method is actually
completely inaccessible
to genomic techniques so i hope with
this example
you can see that there is a need to
directly study the proteins
and it can become useful in clinical
practice
so with that introduction let me first
then
define the terms that we're using so we
can be all on the same page
so proteomics is the large-scale study
of the proteins
and the proteome defines the whole set
of proteins produced
in an organism system or biological
context
and that's thought to be the protein
complement of the genome but of course
that um the proteome includes
differential spiced
proteins truncated proteins post
post-translationally modified proteins
so it's actually a lot bigger than the
genome and to study
this big complex proteome is rather
challenging
and hence our webinar today to discuss
how we can make the measurement of
proteomes
much more robust for clinical research
so the learning objectives today i'd
like to go through
are to consider the types of
quantitative proteomics techniques
consider the challenges and the
specific points which can lead to
irreproducibility or variable data
and then the possible strategies that
we can use to improve it including using
an example from our own research
so now let's consider the type of
clinical research studies
that we might use with proteomics so
quite often this is to
find biomarkers so we i'll use clinical
research
study designs with biomarkers as an
example
and on this slide i'm showing three
commonly or
three possible clinical research study
designs
so the one on the most left is possibly
the simplest
so one does a clinical research trial
with a drug and a placebo
and afterwards um one does a
clinical proteomics analysis of the
collected samples
and come to the analysis where we can
say
patients with particular set of subjects
with particular set of biomarkers
are responsive to this drug whereas a
different profile of biomarkers
are not responsive to this drug so
in this case one would need to evaluate
a significant or
a sufficient number of studies with in
contrast to for example
a cell-based biomedical research
where you might use a minimum three or
four
biological replicates here we will be
looking at a much larger
set of samples in the middle panel it's
a slightly different
design in research where the biomarker
is first
used to select
certain subjects and then undergo the
drug trial
and in on the right side is yet another
design which involves
particularly more different subtypes
where
um the whole cohort is divided into
different groups
and with different stratification then
coming down to the biomarker
selection and biomarker formulation so
you can see in this design then you
would need to enroll even more subjects
or the whole study because you have many
different subgroups
so the whole point from showing you
these
different clinical research study
designs
is to emphasize the point that we need
to have very
robust measurements across hundreds of
clinical samples in such a study
and therefore our proteomic techniques
must be able to reproducibly
measure the same set of proteins across
hundreds of samples now this is
possibly a point that's not really
carefully considered when
developing novel proteomic techniques so
often
proteomic researchers designing new
techniques can spend
a lot of time days or weeks on a single
sample
trying to get the very minute details
and the excellent sensitivity
in this technique and however at the end
of that
it may not really be possible to apply
particular measurement techniques across
hundreds of samples
reproducibly and hence in a clinical
research setting um trying to measure
a lot of proteins across different
samples one may need to come up with a
different strategy
so that brings me to a brief
overview of the key steps that we need
to use in clinical proteomics research
so basically i've broken it down to
three aspects
um in the workflow so first there's the
sample
so in terms of asking a clinical
research question we can
be measuring different types of samples
depending on whether we want to look for
biomarkers where the biomarker sources
are
what are the available samples and also
if we want to ask
mechanicstick questions you might use
tissue or biopsy samples
and possibly together with also
biofluids if we're looking at
proteins that are released to
act on other parts of the body and so
there's a different range of samples
which have different
types of properties different
concentrations and different challenges
in terms of protein extraction so
that's one of the considerations in
terms of the clinical research sampling
uh in the second part the laboratory
analysis there are many many different
steps which could cause variability
during this complex sampling process
so we can consider the protein
extraction
should be reproducible protein
quantitation so measuring the
concentration of your
protein extract that should be accurate
the inclusion of internal standards
um the protein digestion process should
be
again reproducible and then the mass
spectrometry
should reproducibly measure
and quantitate proteins then the mass
spectrometry data
i then passed on to the data now a step
and this usually includes
first the mass spec raw data conversion
to protein identification and
quantification
and we'll consider that in the next
section
and finally there will be the
statistical analysis
of the quantitative proteomics data for
the clinical research questions
that was asked for the entire process
so it's a big study and one needs to
really design the entire study well
from the beginning to get the answers
which are reproducible and may
eventually
be translated to a useful diagnostic
test or molecular mechanism
and revealing drug targets into the
clinic
so then that is that's now considered
the types of quantitative proteomics
techniques are available to us
so ideally when we think about measuring
a lot of samples hundreds of samples
we would prefer in the ideal situation
that for each single sample we just want
to do a single run
with a method that is a standard method
then we can quantitate
all the proteins reproducibly
through the entire cohort
so is it possible with current
proteomics technologies
so let's consider this um in
the context of what mass spectrometry
based proteomics
relies on in terms of its theory
so this is a very simple slide and
probably it's
no news to most of you
so how does mass spectrometry based
proteomics work
so there are two steps the first is
protein identification
and in terms of the commonly used method
where we are talking about
bottom-up proteomics the samples are
usually
protease cleaved to generate a mixture
of peptides
comprising all of the proteins from your
sample
and the mass spectrometry data are then
matched to
a protein database to using different
algorithms
and there are many of them available
each of them could be slightly different
and using um cutoffs which are selected
to minimize
both ids then we match the proteomics
the mass spectrometry data to the
database
so from here you can see um already
certain restrictions that
for example it can only identify or
match
proteins that are actually in the
protein database
and the larger the database there will
be
false discovery rate considerations
which are
a lot of this is now available but it's
when considering clinical proteomics
research we need to bear that in mind so
you should use
an appropriate protein database for
identifying and matching
the proteins so now okay since if let's
say we're happy with our protein
identification method
next we actually really want to get the
quantitation
of different proteins and um
oh no sorry so first uh is uh before
that
before the quantitation i would like to
cover the
peptide selection and identification
part
because this is actually an important
consideration
so how are the different peptides
selected and identified
so usually in bottom-up proteomics
liquid chromatography is used to
separate
the different peptides so that there's
opportunity for different peptides all
to be identified
and broadly then the
peptide precursors are analyzed through
the first
ms so generating the ms-1 spectrum and
then further fragmented
to get the ms2 spectra and in
a common form of shotgun proteomics
the selection of the peptide
usually based on a top number of
peptides for example
top 20 peptides so there's a little bit
of
stochastic selection of peptides
which eventually get fragmented and
identified
so there is one set of
variability in terms of protein
identification and peptide
identification
that one should consider that not all
peptides are being um fragmented
during the mass effect so now we come to
the protein quantification so in the
background of
what i just covered now there are
several
ways that can be used for
protein quantitation and here i'm
showing two
most commonly used methods so
method a is to use the peak height or
area of the ms1
spectra which is measuring the peptide
precursor
and this is quite accurate because
linearity between
there's a linearity relationship between
the peak
haydn area for the same compound that
means the same peptide
an alternative way is to use the
spectral count so the number of
spectra at the ms2
level and based on what i explained
earlier due to
the stochastic selection of the ms-1
peptides that get fragmented this
possibly is slightly less accurate as
using the peak high area because um
some of the the same peptides may not be
selected
because they may not be for example the
top 20
um at that particular retention time
for every single sample that you run in
your hundred
sample cohort for example so this is
another area to consider
so to avoid this issue of the ms-1
the stochastic selection so slightly
i guess semi-random it's based on the
intensity
of the ms-1 there are newer methods that
have been developed
to avoid this selection
so um oh okay so
in this slide just let's let me
backtrack a little bit so
what i described earlier is the data
dependent acquisition
method which we select the most abundant
ions for fragmentation
so the advantages for that is that we
are able to measure
large numbers of peptides in a complex
mixture
but as i i explained just now
there's a stochastic selection so the
same peptide may not be quantified in
all samples in the same cohort
so to avoid this issue
there are um two other methods
that have been developed um so actually
um
selected or multiple reaction monitoring
is a relatively uh
um well established older method so it's
not really new
um in this technique um the
ms1 and the ms2 ions are actually
already pre-selected
so we come into the assay with a list of
ms1
and a matched list of ms2 so we already
should know what we want to measure
and this technique gives very
robust measures of the particular
selected targets
and it gives good quantitation however
it requires prior knowledge and there
is a limit to this certain the number of
targets someone can use for analysis
but it's a highly quantitative measure
so can we have a method that measures
all of the ms-1 and give good
quantitation
so this is what the new newer data
independent acquisition
technique wants to achieve so
this in this technique the ms-1 is
broken down into blocks of independent
um intense independent ms-1
regions which are independent of the
intensity so
the ms-1 peptides are not selected based
on intensity
so all possible ms ms data
are then acquired for all your sample
but then there which is good for
potentially able to measure all
detectable peptides
however then the challenge is in the
computational
aspect because there's in the ms2 level
of spectral library is usually
needed to match and identify
the pep the the peptides and then the
proteins
and so the deconvolution can be rather
challenging
so now we finish considering the
different
quantitative methods
the data independent is relatively new
different clinical programming research
studies are now reporting the data
and the results coming from here the
specific details
of the studies needs to be considered as
well
when you're looking at using this method
so can there be a single lcms
method for all samples that would be
ideal if we don't really need to
develop new methods for every single
study
well that is again not so
straightforward
because the different matrix background
can impact the lcms method
so it can cause answer patient
suppression if there are different mixed
mixtures of peptides which you always
get from
every single different biological source
so for example
a plasma sample proteome would look very
different
from a tissue extract proteome
and so every really every single
type of sample needs to be separately
evaluated
and confirmed that there's no matrix
effect
and suppression so different method of
extraction again
could cause a difference so no
unfortunately
one should not use a single lcms method
for all samples
and then in terms of additional controls
yes it's very good to include internal
standard controls and often this is
using a stable isotope labeled
peptide as a control and later on i'll
discuss additional controls that one can
use
so going back to our wish list no
unfortunately
clinical proteomics research cannot
really use a single method and a single
run for standard sample
so we need to really be a bit smart on
how we design
our studies
so after that technical considerations
for mass spectrometry
now let's get back to thinking about the
clinical
cohort research design for quantitative
using quantitative proteomics techniques
now go back to this slide which i
already
shared with you on the the different
steps that we have to think about
during a clinical proteomics research
study design so let's go through them
in steps so firstly
in terms of the clinical research
sampling we need to think about the
cohort characteristics
so what kind of samples we want what
other questions we are asking
so do you want to find a
body fluid biomarker that could be
sampled easier or do you really need to
use
a tissue sample for diagnosis because
that's what the clinical
practice clinical workflows use
there are various considerations in
terms of the
cohort would you like to match the the
gender do you need to do that
it depends on your question and the
diseases you are studying
what about age do the do the study
subjects and to
fast and is the time of sampling
importance
so should one sample at the same time of
day
additionally the processing procedures
and the storage procedures
should be again consistent across
your cohort but this is particularly
important if there are
multiple sites of clinical sampling
so that each site there should be a
standard operating procedure
across all of the sites so that's on the
clinical side
so in the laboratory and data analysis
aspect
again there are many steps which can
cause different
and course variability during the sample
processing and so here
one must really minimize this technical
variability
so if you quite often
manual protein extraction and processing
are used
with a free technician or post-doc so
even though the person may have
excellent technique just because
one is extracting hundreds of samples
and processing hundreds of samples
there could be variability in the sample
processing
often there's the lack of quality
control measures and we'll discuss how
to
deal with that and we have already
covered the stupid hesitation
of mass spectrometry method this
um we can consider in the by choosing
appropriate mass effect methods and
possibly
slightly compensate through the data
analysis aspect although i wouldn't
recommend really relying on doing this
so one of the um the catholicity
issues from the mass spec method is
leading to
a lot of missing data points so in terms
of data analysis
so sometimes across the subjects
certain protein measurements could be
missing
so that means it was not measured and so
in this case
it may not be very clear whether or not
the protein measurement is zero or it
just did not get selected in the ms1
level
so this is common in the dda approach
when um
mrm method is used where a list of
proteins and peptides
are targeted there's usually low missing
values
and similarly if dia method is used
then there's again low missing values so
this
is one of the points that should be
considered in terms of designing
the data analysis pipelines for the
different types of mass spec
acquisition methods so
further along in terms of in the data
analysis workflow there's a
qc considerations in checking that all
of the
different runs are good quality the
normalization methods
and again the in terms of data analysis
the different algorithms used for
peptide to protein inference
could cause some variability in the
clinical programming research
in terms of that for a single study
obviously one should
use a single algorithm just to don't
have a variable
across different samples so there's
limited choice
in that aspect
so in considering the the workflow
uh one of the important aspects to think
about is the proteome complexity
uh in the mass spectrometry so one of
the limitations
is the speed and the computational
deconvolution algorithms
that are needed to
analyze the data and so in
a sense one needs to
separate and reduce the complexity
at the peptide or protein levels to
allow
increased proteome coverage so we can
identify more proteins
and this can be achieved in several
different ways and has been achieved
in in proteomics research by using
longer mass spectrometry runs in terms
of the lc separation
you can use the multidimensional
separation either at the protein or
peptide level
this then leads to more different mass
spectrometry runs
so again that increased mass spec run
time
so you can see both these options
increase more mass spec time
and quite often the use of mass aspect
time force cost um
for your project so sometimes it may not
be possible depending on the budget for
the research project
apart from the cost issue another
very very important consideration is the
performance of the mass specs so when
you run
a longer time it's quite likely that the
optics in the mass spec becomes more
dirty due to the samples are run through
or for various reasons mathematic
performance
may drop over time and this really needs
to be carefully monitored during the
experiment
to avoid variability that hasn't been
accounted for
so going through then if we want
very deep proteome coverage of large
clinical research cohorts
using for example multi-dimensional mass
spectrometry with long run times
really that we need a very large budget
for our research study
which sometimes may not be available
so how can we perform our research study
in a well-designed manner
you're within reasonable but reasonable
budget
so here are some suggestions which
we've learned through our last few years
work
in this area so in terms of the clinical
research sampling we would
clearly define inclusion exclusion
criteria and to choose
samples very carefully in terms of what
samples we analyze
so unless the research project has
large budgets often we cannot afford to
analyze
all samples collected so
at different stages of the clinical
research you may want to analyze
different types of samples
so by true careful selection
of the samples that you analyze you can
get better quality results and answer
your research question
and additionally as i previously
mentioned having standard operating
procedures
for sample collection and storage is
very
key so we do not want samples to be
already
off variable quality variable
degradation
even before we get to the mass spec
measurement so this is critical
particularly for multi-site studies
then coming to the laboratory aspect
there are
several ways that one can
try and minimize sample variability
during
processing very important
and very useful is to use a liquid
handler for sample processing
and this is not only to save
the hands of your very talented and very
careful
research assistant or postdoc but it
actually
really helps to increase the
reproducibility
of the sample processing
another key measure is to spike in
internal standard protein and assist
labeled peptides
which allows you to check the quality
of the runs and potentially useful
normalization
if required and this helps a little bit
in the data analysis aspect as well
so but still there are a lot of proteins
in samples
in different biological samples
particularly if one is looking at
plasma or serum samples which are
arguably a very
common sample for biomarkers and
it's an easy sample type
for for example a clinical diagnostic
test so one might want to use that as
the
preferred sample type for clinical
proteomics research so how do we deal
about this
one of the approach we've taken is to
focus our research
efforts into subprotigons prior to mass
spec
so this can be chosen according to
a disease pathology so for example
particular post-translational
modifications may be important
in the disease and there could be
methods that are available
or you can develop particular methods to
target this type of
sub-proteome which are
post-translationally modified
and relevant to your disease and this
can actually in a single step
easily reduce the complexity of the
proteome another
example is particular cellular
organelles
social locations for example quite
popular it's now the
uh extracellular vesicles which are
released from cells
and this package proteins to send to
other parts of the cell and that could
be used
for as the isolation method so generally
a potential idea to reduce sample
complexity
that's relevant to the disease will help
to reduce sample complexity
going into the mass spec and that will
improve the quantitative robustness
of your entire workflow
and so now come to the question of
study design so again
if one has unlimited funds
to run a lot of studies then one could
consider
analyzing deep proteome for all samples
for all cohorts
however this often is not practicable in
terms of
how long the mass spec will be
maintaining the
standard of instrument that we would
like
to have for the for the analysis
as well as in terms of the cost
so in
instead of doing the rectangular design
which is shown on the left of this slide
which is very often used for genomic
studies proteomics studies have often
used
the triangular design which is shown on
the right side of the study
and in this design there are different
phases of study starting from the top
of the pyramid where the number of
samples
so the cohorts are starts with a small
cohort so in this step one would
carefully select
and match the samples the subjects
and then one may use
a dia or cda method
to measure as many proteins as possible
and i would still apply for a sub
proteome approach if possible and
after that a set of candidates are
selected through the statistical
analysis
then a validation or verification cohort
or qualification cohort different terms
have been applied to this
is then used as an intermediate step and
often
one might design a mrm assay to very
accurately quantitate
the small subset of candidates
and this can then lead to an even
smaller subset although
environment assays could measure
around 50
or tens of proteins so it may not need
to really go into an antibody based
stage
towards the end so
faced study design is um quite feasible
in terms of cost and
allows a different selection and
different type
of proteomic methods during the steps
and so overall what this side is
summarizing now
the different steps that one might
consider at each
of the stages or each of the workflow
during a clinical proteomics research
project
so in terms of the clinical research
sampling
design the studying for a focused
question and
if possible using longitudinal sampling
from the sun set of subjects
is quite useful because each subject
will provide multiple samples and
act as their own control which takes
away some of the biological
variability across people
we can consider stage relevant sample
selection if the triangular design is
used
so for that what would one would do
is to use
a well-matched sample at the start
and then going to broader selection of
subjects
for the later stages and again cannot
emphasize
enough the standard operating procedure
for sample collection
processing and storage uh in terms of
the laboratory analysis aspect
i would suggest to target a sub proteome
if possible
include internal standing as a qc
use liquid handler for sample processing
and
a very good practice um which i've
learned
during our research is to actually
run through the entire procedure that
has been established
using for example a single sample would
run a few times
to determine the robustness or
variability
of the entire procedure before starting
the whole cohort
that way you know what is the
variability
that occurs just through the sample
processing
then you can be more confident of your
result at the end
so finally in the data analysis analysis
aspect
you can definitely check um
your whole data set initially for
overall quality and if there are any
outliers either due to technical
reason or a biological reason um those
outliers
should be removed from further analysis
the mass spec stability across long
across large cohorts definitely should
also be analyzed
so usually there should be mass spec qc
samples for example
often used hela digest for example or a
bsa
digest just
inserted during your sample sequence to
ensure the mathematic
performance is the same across weeks
or months of run for your entire cohort
normalization can be used
as well and finally one should apply a
suitable
statistical analysis to answer the
clinical questions
so now finally i just
want to share a practical example from
our research
so the example i'd like to share with
you is
our discovery of serum protein
biomarkers
for early detection of esophageal
adenocarcinoma
now this is the cancer that develops at
the lower esophagus
most patients that suffer from this
disease are diagnosed at late incurable
stages
leading to a median survival rate of
less than one year
there is a recognized pre-malignant
condition called
barrett's esophagus and the disease
progression then usually occurs
through various oesophagus to high grade
dysplasia which is intermediate stage
and then progressing to esophageal
adenocarcinoma
the whole procedure can be up to 10
years
there are also recognized risk factors
including reflux disease
and males also obesity
are strong risk factors for this disease
now one of the clinical needs is to
develop a more effective diagnostic
test for surveillance or screening
currently the surveillance of various
esophagus patients are done
by endoscopy with biopsy and this is an
invasive procedure and
health economics studies have shown that
the procedure
is not cost effective because of the
load progression rate
and the long time required for disease
progression
so there's the need for biomarkers which
can
detect early disease meaning high grade
dysplasia
stage and for the test to be
less invasive so we aimed to
discover serum protein biomarkers for
this
application and we wanted to discover
markers that can pick up
a high grade dysplasia rather than a
late stage
cancer so to cut a long story short
we decided to focus on glycoproteins
because there's a
literature suggesting that glycosylation
is changed
in during cancer development in general
and during esophageal adenocancer
adenocarcinoma development in particular
and what we decided to do was to set up
a
high throughput screening method using a
liquid handler
and in this method we use individual
lectins
each coupled to a magnetic bead an array
of
individual lectins coated with beads on
the 96 well
lectins are natural proteins which
their job is to find different types of
glycosylation glycosylated proteins
so we use it as a tool to isolate
different types of glycosylated
proteins this has been used
quite a lot in glycobiology the
difference with our method
is that we use individual lectins and we
initially selected
20 different lectins to use to screen
against one serum
and in this method then the
individual serum samples are
denatured and we added a chicken of
albumen to each
serum sample at the start as an internal
standard so we can monitor
the entire workflow by
chicken of albumin peptides which are
not in any of our samples
so after that the denatured proteins
are captured at the protein level with
the
individual lectin bees on the 96 well
the wash proteins the unbound proteins
are washed away
and then we did on bead tryptic digest
procedure
which then we can collect the
peptides from the supernatant for mass
spec analysis
and the entire workflow was set up on a
bravo liquid handler
platform so
the study cohorts were used so we
chose a triangular workflow
and initially in the first stage we had
10 patients per group and we analyzed
healthy the barriers of esophagus and
the cancer group and
we used dda acquisition method
and we had 20 different lectins here so
we screened
a large number of proteins in this
method
from there we chose six lectins as the
most promising
and designed mrm against
around 50 proteins which came out as
candidates
and in the second phase we analyzed 20
patients per group
and the groups are again the same as the
first face healthy
varys oso vigorous and cancer and from
the qualification phase we chose
four lectins which were the most
promising and we actually just used the
same mrm assay
but this time we included a um
labeled peptide to some of our top
candidates
to increase the robustness of the meshes
and in the final phase we measured a
large
broad range of samples from an
australian cohort as well as from
a small cohort from the us and
at this stage we added the
dysplasia samples so low grade and high
grade dyslexia
and the goal here is to find define a
biomarker signature which can
detect high grade dysplasia and cancer
labelled in red here so these are the
treatment the
groups that will receive treatment and
then we
want to distinguish this group from the
healthy baristas objects and low-grade
dysplasia
now the results were of all these stages
were published in these two studies
the final outcome is we found a 10
glycoprotein biomarker
panel which can detect high grade
dysplasia and esophageal cancer as
a group from the other group that don't
need treatment
and the specificity for in the final
stage we divided our
cohort into a training cohort which was
used to develop this 10 marker panel
which has a specificity and sensitivity
over 85
then we used that biomarker panel to
test
the usa cohort and the sensitivity and
specificity as
expected in this scenario was lower than
the
training cohort but it's still fairly
reasonable and this is a quite promising
result from these different cohorts
so finally um just reminds me to
summarize what we went through
today so we
consider the key
aspects of variability in proteomic
research using clinical cohorts and
some practical solutions that could
achieve robustness
in the quantitative proteomics analysis
of large clinical cohorts
and then i gave you an example of what
how we
discovered serum glycoprotein biomarkers
for early
esophageal adenocarcinoma and
that involves the use of magnetic b
coupled
lectins and which we then developed
within multiple reaction monitoring
assay
allowing validation in clinical cohorts
of several hundred samples over the
three months run we
achieved excellent reproducibility
for the spiked in standard so we were
quite confident of the result
so now we're looking at further
developing the assay
for clinical use in the future
so thank you very much for joining me
today and hopefully
there are some tips that you have
learned from today's webinar
and i'd be very happy to answer any
questions
you dr hill for your informative
presentation now as you mentioned we
will now start the live q a portion of
our webinar
to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have some
great questions already coming in
dr hill let's start with this one should
one be concerned about batch effects
in clinical proteomics research
thank you for that that's a very good
question and the answer is
yes so one
thing that i actually neglected to
mention and yes thank you for the
question
is that the um the cohorts the samples
should be randomized
during the run so that means um the
for example the cancer and the
non-cancer samples
should be mixed in order so one should
not run
or sample all cancer samples at the
start and all non-cancer samples at the
end
and in terms of the batch effect that's
one of the reasons of batch effect if
you are running autumn
for example group a at the start when
the mass spec is in very good condition
and then you see a drop in mass effect
performance to
during the end of the run when group b
are all run
and that's one of the reasons that one
should randomize samples
and the second reason a second way to
randomize is if you have multiple
micro plates for example or different
batches of processing then one should
definitely randomize the samples across
different plates or batches of
processing and that means
group a and group b should be in both
plates or batches
thank you dr hill now this next question
is two parts
do you have any recommendations for
cohort size and selection for biomarker
studies
and should samples be matched for
clinical parameters across study groups
thank you for the question um so
the cohort size is
slightly variable so um
it depends again on the number available
and the study design that you go with
so i can comment more on the triangular
study design which is what we have done
so you would have seen in our initial
study
in the first phase we just did 10
samples per group
in later studies we've moved to 20
samples per group
although the 10 samples per group gave
good results we
wanted to use more and we had the budget
to do more in later studies
so probably around yeah 15 to 20 at the
initial
stage is good quite often
a sample size calculation may be asked
for when you for example do grant
applications
however if you don't have any data it's
just a discovery stage
you really cannot do a sample size
calculation
um accurately as such so
say yeah i would say yeah between 10 and
20 per group is a good
size to start with for selection in the
initial
phase the discovery stage i would
recommend
to match samples very well between your
groups so group a and b
definitely should be age and sex matched
and
any other potential confounding factors
it's
possibly good to match them so you get
very homogeneous results
and you get candidates going forward to
the next phases
for next phases then i would relax
the sample matching criteria so you can
really observe how the candidates are
performing
across the different types of samples
that you have
thank you dr hill now we have time for a
few more questions
spiking in an internal standard protein
is a good idea
should that protein be used to normalize
normalized samples
such as one would use actin for western
blots
um yeah that's a good question so yeah
indeed yeah i like
to add in an internal standard protein
to
check the quality of the workflow
for each of the samples
particularly when you have a cohort of a
few hundred
even using liquid handler occasionally
there may be some samples that just did
not get a good quality
processing and then one could see
that the internal standard um peptides
that were generated from the spiked in
protein so which we're using
um albumin chicken of argument in the
example i gave
so um the use of
that for normalization is
um good when the samples are not
too variable so if it's clear
that one of the samples there was a
problem with the processing and for
example you hardly see
any of your internal standard peptide
then i would actually
remove that sample from the rest of the
analysis
on the basis that something went wrong
during the processing and the data is
is low quality rather than normalized
if there's only small variability
between
samples for the internal standard
protein then yes indeed you can use
this internal standard protein for
normalization
that would be my suggestion
thank you dr hill we have time for one
more question with the invention of data
independent
acquisition will shotgun proteomics and
targeted proteomics be abandoned
in the future
that's a good question so um the dia
acquisition um has been used in few
studies now
it has some advantages and i think we
are still
learning uh on all of the details on how
it works
so at the moment the other two
approaches are still used quite a lot
the mrn assay may
not probably will not be abandoned
because
in the clinical laboratories
mrm assays are used to measure
metabolites and so it's a workflow
that the clinical labs are already used
for diagnostic
purposes so in terms of translating
clinical proteomics research to clinical
assays and the mrm assay is a very good
bridge
so i would think that
using mrosa as that link between
research and implementation would be a
good idea and that's
in fact what we are aiming to do with
our essay
so thank you for that question
and thank you dr hill i'd also like to
thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
those questions we were unable to answer
today and those that are submitted
during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by dr hill via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
i would once again like to thank dr
michelle hill for her time today
and for her important research we'd also
like to thank labyrus
and our sponsor agilent for underwriting
today's educational webcast
today's presentation is educational and
it does offer continuing education
credits
if you are interested in receiving your
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
you may continue to submit questions
during the on-demand period
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day